[Music]
uh
hello
good to see you all
all right so we have got a um
interesting evening planned out for you
guys but i want to say i'm glad to see
you guys here um thank you for those who
are paying attention online who tuned in
my name's don jacobs um i am one of the
leadership people here at the table and
i'm glad to
be here with you guys um so we do have
like some interesting things going on
tonight so we're going to have a guest
speaker i'll introduce him later i'm
actually looking very looking forward to
this because
when he came into the church i kind of
knew a little bit about his background
and i was like oh he's going to speak
one day and it's going to be awesome so
tonight is that night so i'm looking
forward to it um
and then um we also have a
guest um
music minister tonight so um we're going
to be uh you know carter livingston
who's been part of our family for
a long time talented musician we're
actually thrilled that he's here so he's
going to be kind of leading us through
worship tonight so i'm looking forward
to that
because of some interesting events that
happen in you know brett's family and
everything like that we have to move our
state of the table meeting that we did
have originally scheduled for tonight uh
we're gonna push it back for two weeks
uh it's gonna be september 26
i think i'm saying that correctly um so
yes i'm getting some affirmations i'm
doing really good with that date um so
uh so it's gonna be two weeks uh two
sundays from now so i'm again as i've
mentioned this before and we've said
this out in other uh announcements this
is kind of like a family meeting we just
want to kind of talk to you guys about
like what's going on with the table
um any kind of you know upcoming events
and some changes that might be happening
we'll talk about some financial things
and even just kind of places where um
like either ministry opportunities or
whatever so we would love for you to be
part of that conversation and be able to
hear that
so
with that being said
i'm going to start us off with a word of
prayer
lord thank you so much
for just bringing us here together um
thank you for just
just the ability to come and to worship
to
tune in and to have a space where we can
focus on you
no matter what this week is brought for
us um whether we have lots of highs lots
of lows
or just a mundane week
we can bring that here lay that at your
feet um hopefully get some peace about
some things um most definitely want to
be able to have a sense of joy about
some of the things that we are carrying
with us
but just knowing that you're here to
be with us in spirit
i pray for um
carter tonight that she will just give
him a lot of
grace and empowerment tonight as he's
leading us in worship i pray for mike
that you will give him
words that will speak to
our hearts and
just
open our hearts and minds into
what you have for us tonight in christ
in my prayer amen
thanks don
if you're all welcome to stand up and
join in along with us
we definitely love to hear voices
singing along with us
so
[Music]
you broke my chains of sin and shame and
you covered me
[Music]
with grace
and you are the hand that reaches out
safe
i am set free
[Music]
free
you broke my chains of sin and shame and
you covered me with grace
[Music]
with grace
[Applause]
[Music]
that i am
set free
[Music]
it is for freedom
that i am
set free
[Music]
do
yes lord we
are
grateful for
your grace and for your
love
[Music]
yes lord we
are grateful
for your grace
and for your
love
yes lord we are
grateful for your grace and for your
love
yes lord we
are
grateful for your grace
yes lord we
are grateful
for your grace and for
your love
yes lord we
are grateful
for your grace
[Music]
wow
it is
[Music]
it is for freedom
that is
[Music]
do
worthy of every song we could ever see
[Music]
worthy of all the praise we could ever
bring
[Music]
worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe
we live for you
[Music]
jesus name above every other day
jesus the only one you could ever save
[Music]
worthy of every breath we could ever
there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes in wonder
show me
who you are
me
jesus is the name above every other name
jesus
[Music]
there is no one like
show me
who you are
[Music]
there is no one like you there is
to those around me
[Music]
i will build my life
upon your love it is a
foundation i will put my trust in you
alone
and i will not be
shaken i will build my life
upon your
love it is a firm
foundation
i will put my trust in you alone
[Music]
it is
show me who you
[Music]
there is no one like you
there is no decide you
open up my eyes in wonder show me
who you are and fill me
with your heart and lead me
[Music]
so this part of the service has uh
become a favorite part of mine is when
we do the prayers for the people it's
such a beautiful thing
that
we come together as a as a group and we
we lift up our friends
here at the church and maybe outside the
church
in prayer and try to just offer support
because that's that's what we're about
right supporting each other
and supporting people here
and it's just
it's just a wonderful thing so
we're gonna
we're gonna do what uh
what we typically do and if you if you
if you're new new here
we're just gonna i'm gonna say we're
gonna say a prayer together and then
we're going to lift up the names of the
people that we want to live on
for the city of sac c texas
and for every city and community
and all those who live in them we pray
to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom
and will to conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
the prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
and so we lift up these names and
situations to you
i'm going to repeat this for online
janet's sister and brett's aunt carolyn
two weeks in icu healing for her lungs
from online
please pray for janet tilford
from online healing for mindy melody
janet and the tilford family
from online nancy's chemo
lord for the names and moments we have
spoken about for those who we have kept
in our hearts
we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
you give life
you are love
you bring light
to
the darkness
you give hope
you restore
every heart
that is broken
great
all you know
it's your breath
in my lungs
so we pour out our prey
pour out our praises your breath
in our lungs
so we pour out our prey
[Music]
give life
you are love
you bring light
to
the
darkness you give up
you restore
every heart
that is
[Music]
your breath
me
[Music]
and all the earth will shout your praise
our hearts will cry these bones will
sing
great
[Music]
[Laughter]
our hearts will cry these bones will
sing
made
are
you
lord
all the earth will shout your prayers
our hearts will cry these bones will
sing
great all the earth will shout your
grace our hearts will cry these bones
will win
[Music]
your hearts will cry these balls
pour out our praises your breath
in our loves
so we pour out our breaks pour out our
praises your breath
in our lungs
so we
[Music]
it's your breath
so we pour out our prey
[Music]
all right so i oh excuse me i'm gonna
get out of your way
okay so i want to be able to introduce
mike to you real quick um but i'm going
to see that brett since brent's not here
he did want me to share
this
quick introduction so i want to share
via brett
about about this so he says hey table
family i miss you all
but i'm pumped that you get to hear from
um the great mike miller tonight
mike and marilyn are amazing people and
i'm glad that you will get
all get to know them in the coming years
uh they have pla planned multiple
churches and pastored a number of
different congregations in their 40
years
or so ministry
and in the community that is desperate
in need for spiritual fathers and
mothers we are lucky to have the two of
the best
so please give mike a warm welcome
tonight
so here we go praise god awesome
well i'm uh
pleased to be able to fill in for brett
tonight but i'm not pleased we have to
fill in for brett tonight
you know so
it's sad that we understand
what everybody's going through right now
all the concerns that people have
marilyn and i uh just uh we retired
almost two years ago now from pastoring
we pastored for 42 years up in fort
collins colorado
and uh
in in the same town we pastored three
different churches in three different
periods of time
so it uh
but at any rate we're uh we're thrilled
to be here we hadn't been in church for
quite a while
uh
because of a lot of what's going on in
the in the uh in the church right now
with regard to what brett's been talking
about for the last several weeks
deconstruction
you know and there were a lot of things
going on that were just
pretty overbearing over the last several
years and so you know we just were
just staying away for a little while
relaxing and
and marilyn got online one day because
she thought it's about i'd been sitting
around the house just about long enough
not going to church
and she looked for a church and she
found one that said inclusion and she
said let's go try this and we did and we
love it and i you know i'm 75 years old
so i can't say i'm here forever but i'm
here for a while
so anyway
and she's much younger than me obviously
she's be 39 next birthday
yeah amen
no you know oh i'm supposed to turn this
start thing on because i got this in 25
minutes i've never done anything except
heat a cup of coffee in 25 minutes so
i've really got to be careful tonight
i'm learning a new way to minister but
but we all know or should know if you've
been here that brett's been on
on this thing called deconstruction now
for several weeks
and uh
you know it's um it's it's a term that
that communicates implies the tearing
down almost the violent you know tearing
down if you ever watch them tear down a
building you know there's there's a
certain amount of violence involved in
that so to speak
and and it implies you know the tearing
down and the rearranging of that which
uh has become our uh our structure
uh and our and our habitat in other
words a place where we've taken up
residence and and maybe uh
just our
just hanging around the house that's all
we're doing we're hanging around the
house got nothing else going on in our
lives you know
and so this deconstruction thing has uh
has become a major thing but
i want to be careful tonight
i've necessarily had to miss a few of
the lessons over the last several weeks
and so i want to be careful tonight you
know not to throw brett's plan over for
the next few weeks off track so
basically what i'm going to do is rather
than try to teach i'm just going to
offer up tonight some of my observations
and a little bit about the experience
that marilyn and i have had
over the many years that we
that we did pastor and so on so
and some of this may be uh redundant
because as i said i haven't heard
everything that brett has said
uh i'm i'm sorry that i haven't but but
uh
but some of it i may say some things
that brett has already said uh it'll do
you good to hear them a second time
uh if i say some things that contradict
brit he's your pastor stick with him
okay
and then he can deal with me later on he
can correct me later via email don't
talk to me face to face about it though
because none of us like to be corrected
face to face right
anyway okay i just want to make sure you
understood that first of all let me say
this that deconstruction is the result
of
rethinking you know re-examining
reconsidering
you know the uh
the ideas and beliefs that we've heard
and learned and settled into comfortably
uh
you know from wherever we got them
parents church
society i know that's a bit redundant i
did hear him say that
but you know as i say re thinking and re
possibly we never thought
or considered or examined in the
beginning that's probably uh a pretty
accurate thing to say for a lot of us
who were just
fed certain things by our
parents or by vacation bible school or
whatever as we were growing up maybe we
never did really rethink them we don't
need to rethink them we never thought
them you know what i'm saying
but
i want to say this too that
deconstruction is active it's not
something that just happens to you that
you just wake up one morning and you
find gee my beliefs have changed you
know i no longer have settled in that
it's something that requires activity on
our part
and uh and that's why it's uh peculiar
right now to to particular groups of
people
because there are
particular groups of people that have
determined to become active in the
pursuit of a more relevant truth
something that that speaks more
peacefully to their heart
you know what i mean
all right so
destruction uh deconstruction
destruction deconstruction isn't for the
lazy it's not for the weak it's not for
the squeamish you know because first of
all you know deconstruction
as i said requires you to to begin to
ask
questions
it requires you to ask questions like
how did i get where i am today
with with regard to my belief system you
know
where did this come from
and maybe even from a historical
perspective where did this originate
there's a lot of that there's a lot of
things when we get in begin to looking
through things we find out that that
certain things kind of originated
along the way
sometimes in opposition to somebody
else's movement and we felt like it was
somebody along the way felt like it was
necessary to to uh to put that one into
silence put that one to bed and so they
came up with something new i mean this
this is all prevalent really throughout
the the history of christianity and so
on so
but anyway so
why do i believe why have i why do i
believe to be true what i now to believe
to be true
we need to ask ourselves that why do i
and this is a healthy question to ask
yourself anyway even if you're not
really struggling with anything it's a
good good healthy thing to to ask
yourself why do i believe to be true
what i now believe to be true
and i'll tell you these are questions
that i discovered questions that your
peers your family and certainly your
your your ministry many ministry people
don't want you asking
because remember a lot of these things
have become our place of security just
like your home is your security we've
settled down in here it's a secure place
to be
and you know there's a lot of there's a
lot of i've discovered it over the years
we've lost a lot of ministry peer
friends relationships over the years
and uh and you might say well it's
probably your attitude yeah probably you
know it could very well be you know
that's what they all said it was they
said it was my bad attitude you know
and uh but anyway
it also requires you though it requires
of us deconstruction requires of us to
respectfully and i'm gonna put that word
in all caps to respectfully disagree
with and to reject
even again respectfully accepted beliefs
that you can't er
while you still have the idea
no idea i mean what the better thing
might be let me say that again
because this this was something that was
was really uh present in my heart
for years
i had
certain things that i just rejected in
my heart my heart just couldn't accept
them they just didn't sound right even
though they came from
ministry authority people you know
i didn't know what the better thing
might be
but i just couldn't accept
the thing that was being offered does
that make sense to you
and so it requires us
a
a fruitful deconstruction requires of us
you know to to be willing to
respectfully disagree with and reject
and dispute the accepted belief while
having no idea what the better thing
might be
it's saying you know
i have a sense that something's out of
whack but i just can't put my finger on
it
any of you ever had that kind of thing
where there's something that just seems
out of you know that it's become it's
become a standard maybe in your
in your background where you were where
you were what you were listening to the
same thing was spoken over and over and
over and over
um
i'll give you one years and years and
years ago we were
drawn into a group
for a different reason totally that we
discovered when we got in there that
they were just
not knee-deep
neck deep in prosperity doctrine and
there was something about that that just
in my heart it said there's just
something about that's not right
but i didn't know what it was it wasn't
right
and so marilyn and i chose to reject the
idea of that
see the the things that we were hearing
why not yet knowing what the better
thing was
in the years since then we've come to
understand the better thing and i'm not
going to go into all that but anyway
so
destruction i keep saying destruction
because that's what it is deconstruction
i should say you know frees me to no
longer passively agree with these soul
troubling
these soul troubling doctrines and
practices you know where my heart just
can't see it it frees me that's this is
the wonderful thing about deconstruction
you know it really produces freedom
you can't see it when you start into it
you know you can't see it when you're up
against it and when you're being opposed
by the by those who who
are rejecting what you're doing you you
can't see it but it's it's you're on the
road to freedom you're on the road to a
liberty and a and a sense of uh
freedom and so again
my heart just can't see it but instead
rather than being passively accepting
you know i become aggressive i become
relentless in questioning i'm not
talking about becoming aggressive
in in
disputing with other people that'll get
you nowhere fast most of us know that
you know look at people on facebook
today
you know
just go ahead and offer a different
opinion i dare you you know
and uh and same could be said for a lot
of us you know i mean i read some other
people's opinion and boy i'll tell you
it's all i can do to hold back you know
but i already realized it it's not going
to do any good to say anything right so
but that's not what but i need to be
able to be aggressively uh
rejecting that thought anyway
and and questioning questioning
aggressively
questioning aggressively okay but so why
do i need to deconstruct this is i've
had people ask me this question in the
past why do i need to deconstruct
you know
well sounds like i'm done
something you'd do in a space movie
right just deconstruct
be gone but anyway
here's this deconstruction becomes a
necessity because i've settled
because i've become sedentary
now think about this i've become settled
something is
something is true because i heard it
when i was growing up in the
presbyterian church in the sunday school
class and that's the final word right
and i've become settled in that and
that's something that i'm going with and
that and you're not going to change my
mind right well what do i need i need an
overhaul i need a deconstruction i need
the
the violence
my soul i need the violence of having to
rethink my position i need the violence
of having to reconsider re-examine
re-evaluate all those reads or again as
i said a while ago maybe it's the first
time i've thought
or evaluated what's going on okay but
that's why we need it
contrary to common thought
and
this will probably speak to some of you
at least
our beliefs should be fluid
our beliefs should be ever evolving
if you believe the same thing now that
you believed a year ago
you're sedentary
if you're still believing the same
things that you were introduced to
christianity with now i'm not saying
some of those things you shouldn't
believe i'm just saying if your beliefs
have not evolved
if they're not ever ever if they're not
fluid if they're not ever evolving
then you need to say well possibly i'm
sedentary possibly i have settled into a
place
where
i'm there's no growth going on in my
life see what i'm saying that's why i
need it
okay and
it should be evolving
through the constant process of of
testing
examination questioning and a judgment
and adjustment you know paul said
um
ii corinthians 13 i think examine
yourselves to see whether you are in the
faith he's not talking about examining
your behavior
and then he said after that test
yourselves examine yourselves to see
whether you are in the faith test
yourselves he's not talking about see
the church has turned that many times
into a you need to take a look at the
way you've been acting
you better examine your behavior and see
if you've been in the faith that's not
at all what paul was referring to paul
was referring to examining what what
your heart was was considering to be
valuable
what your heart was believing
to see whether you're in the faith is
what he said
okay he didn't say to see whether you're
in in agreement with the law
right okay
so
and you know we've got these
holy trios my goodness this time is
going by that can't possibly be right on
it is it okay no more no more all right
man it's tough to be tough to pastor her
i know how you do it brett
[Laughter]
just to settle for knowledge alone
really handicaps us
i'll tell you why and the reason for
that is because there's no movement
that's resident within knowledge alone
we sit in church we absorb knowledge
knowledge alone is not enough right but
but the the
the mechanism of movement is wisdom and
wisdom is what i'm talking about you
know testing examination questioning
another place paul says prove all things
hold fast that which is good prove all
things see that's wisdom and then
understanding is the adjustment it's
it's it's the adjustment the
recalculation
now and going along with this a term
that we hear a lot in the church and i
kind of want to clear this up if for you
if if it needs clarity maybe you don't
is this term revelation or or revelation
knowledge and when we use that term or
when we hear that term we often think in
terms of
a final word
the last thing the end nothing more to
be said right
but the truth of the matter is
that
revelation implies a progressive
unfolding
and in the words of jesus it's like this
the sower sows the word he sows the seed
and he said the seed comes forth first
the blade
then the grain
he said then the head then the mature
grain in the head and when the crop
permits see you hear the fluidity in
that see jesus is talking about the
fluidity of revelation
the sower sows the word
and then this is how it progresses a
blade a head
full grain in the head
it comes to harvest see what i'm saying
there's a fluidity there
now as i've said you know deconstruction
really suggests a violent action or a
modification
of some fixed position
that that and by violence
obviously i'm not talking about an
outward violence i'm talking about that
disconcerting upheaval
that you get in your soul when all of a
sudden you come face to face with the
fact that maybe you've been
you know
wallering in
garbage
in terms of doctrine for quite some time
you know
and i just know that um
i just know that uh
there's a lot of you that have because i
i know we we should had that opportunity
over the years you know
when we when i first began to hear
people using this harsher term though of
deconstruction
it really didn't appeal to me just
simply because i really had never been
fixed in anything
but
not gonna make it i'm not gonna make it
i'm not going to be okay
well let me jump ahead here real quick
well we were one one of the things that
we
determined to do when we first entered
the ministry 40 well
five 44
five years ago now we determined to
always be upfront with
people that we were pastoring and you
know let them know what our questions
were keeping our questions before them
keeping our
perceived answers before them letting
them know when we were making a change
in our thought process letting them know
i regularly let them know when when i
now had discovered that you know
something that i had taught in the past
i no longer value this as accurate
and we did that continually so nothing
was really fixed i was fluid in my
thinking from the time that we came into
the ministry we both were
and uh
but as i said it cost us some friends uh
it cost his people all the time
especially when i when i would bump up
against you know
those certainties you have any
certainties in your life
better prepared to lose them
you know things about little things like
don't ask me questions now i haven't had
time i've only got jimmy christmas
anyway
infallibility of scriptures eternal
conscious torment you know certain end
times suggestions
sexual lifestyle issues
just methodologies of living the
christian life
you bump up against some of those things
and those were certainties at a point in
my life or in point in somebody's life
certain ways this is the way you stay in
fellowship with god this is the way you
you know this is the way you must live
your life in order to be so on and so
forth right
but my piece in the process came several
years ago you know with the
consideration of the incarnation
the incarnation we know is the
foundational act of christianity is that
no other foundation can be laid than
that which is jesus christ and him
crucified right okay
that's the incarnation but when we use
that term incarnation most people think
immediately of bethlehem as though
bethlehem in you know
is the incarnation but that's not true
at all i mean that's partially true
that's a portion of the truth but
according to paul in 1st timothy chapter
1 verses 9 and 10 the incarnation
is the saving revelation of the purpose
and grace of god which was given to us
in christ jesus before time began
and has now been revealed by the
appearing of our lord savior jesus
christ who has has abolished death and
brought life and immortality to light
through the gospel so right there we
have a revelation that's from before
time began
through it you know given to us it says
from before time given to us
that was then those people then but it's
given to us
from before time began you know through
it through this a time called the time
of appearing right on into
and through immortality so that's that's
a progressively unfolding very fluid
revelation right now most of us have
heard in most of our christian life that
that jesus is the revelation of the
father that's absolutely true but he is
also known to be the perfect revelation
of true humanity
you know
as seen through the grace of god from
before time began
during time and after time so in other
words when you look at jesus you're
supposed to understand that what you're
seeing is god's revelation of humanity
from before time during time and after
time in other words god never has seen
anything any different about anybody wow
hard to believe can't do you can't buy
that okay no it's true
so it's a progressively unfolding
eternal
and eternally fluid revelation
and i began to see that the church had
had harvested had been harvesting
revelation many times
from from before the blade
trying to create
you know what i'm saying
before it was time to be harvested been
trying to harvest and communicate
doctrines
you know before it was ready to come to
fruition and so we have a lot of talk a
lot of revelation
you know uh that that actually has never
been allowed to come to fruition and so
we even
we've invested our time and our energies
into these things many times and it has
really
left us with that sense in here
something's wrong i just can't put my
finger on it i don't know what it is
right
so from this question though
uh
occurred to me
and i've talked about this many times
over the years what was and i'm going to
say is what is the mission and the
message of this incarnation the
incarnation i've just described to you
from before the time began
having appeared
on into the age of immortality right
what is the mission and the message of
the incarnation and out of that i got
these questions that came to me all the
time what then is the heartbeat of jesus
what is the revelation or the
progressive unfolding of the cross and
the resurrection what is the liberty of
the gospel
see these questions became my obsession
they became my every minute of study
they became my every minute of inquisit
of inquisition basically
i discovered that
i began to live more and more
in respectful disagreement
even peaceful defiance
with many of the premature cuttings that
were presented by much of the church i
say the premature those harvested
those harvested doctrines tried to
harvest it out of a field of grass field
of blade rather than a field of wheat
right
i don't have the time obviously to take
you through the hours and hours of study
and the messages that came out of all of
that over the years but i can do this in
conclusion
yep i'm going to do it
i can tell you where my where my
inquisition took me and i can assure you
that it'll take you progressively to the
same vicinity and i say vicinity leaving
room
for additional changes in my own
understanding but i'm telling you the
vicinity is solid
the vicinity is solid this is where
those questions what is the message and
the mission of the incarnation what is
the heartbeat of jesus see what is the
liberty of the gospel and so on
and this is where this is where
i mean my wife can tell you all of my
study
all of my ministry for the last many
years is it's where it came to
the mission and the message of the
incarnation
is the abolishing of every criteria of
exclusion
i'm putting that number one that's the
message
and the mission
of this
from before the beginning of time
forever
this this this revelation of the purpose
and grace of god that was given us in
christ jesus from before time began
right
the heartbeat of jesus i mean
think about it there's so many exclusive
exceptions
to the faith that we have in the loving
merciful god i mean the church has made
these exceptions but that's what it is
the abolition of all of that
the heartbeat of jesus is the
elimination of every consideration of
separation or distance from abba
every consideration you know all those
references to backsliding
see that's it
when someone talks about backsliding
that's a reference that came right out
of the pit of hell
because the heartbeat of jesus is to
eliminate every consideration of
separation or even momentary distance
from god
from the father
the revelation of the cross and the
resurrection is is the release from the
imagination of alienation from the
father's grace because of any omission
or commission
have you been told the father doesn't
answer your prayers if
say you can't get your prayers answered
if or or you've got to do penance before
or you've got to do this or the other
thing before that's what i'm talking
about those things that that
that alienate you from the father's
grace because you omitted to do it or
you
did it whatever all right
and the liberty of the gospel is to be
able to realize and recognize all men
included everywhere for all time
you know i was talking with brett
several weeks ago and one of the things
that has bothered me
about previous
whatever
we've had with inclusion
speaking people
we're going to include the uh we're
going to invite into our into our
fellowship into our place uh the the the
gay community we're gonna invite them in
and we're going to include them
and and and with the idea that if
they're here with us long enough they'll
change
that's not inclusion
that's an exceptionalist that's an
exclusionary way of thinking say what
i'm saying it's it's it's there's all
there's all manner of that stuff that
we've allowed to happen but so the
liberty of the gospel is to realize and
recognize all men included everywhere
for all time and now as i said
i promise you that every true greek
deconstruction is going to bring you to
these conclusions
and they're going to wreck many of your
certainties along the way and boy i wish
i had some time to talk i don't have any
time to talk at all i've been robbed
but let me say this the incarnation is
not so much the foundational act of
christianity which is what we normally
think of it is but more accurately it's
the foundational act of inclusion
revealed from before time began into the
age of immortality
and so when you stop and consider all of
the things
all of the possibilities i mean we could
go on all night all of us
all of the things that that suggests
exclusion
separation
distance
come out of him in the name of jesus
my wife set that up
i'm known as the guy who can't say
anything in 25 minutes and i've just
proved it
this was a race to the end here anyway
but
but again you know i really want to uh
and i would
my best guess would be that probably
there's a lot of deconstruction going on
in the hearts of you folks that you
wouldn't be here
and uh and i and i just want you to to
to consider
you know
the big picture
and and the the big picture relates to
those four things that i've talked about
what is the message
and the mission of the gospel i mean of
the of the incarnation what is the
heartbeat of jesus you know what is the
liberty of the gospel
and whatever the
other one was i said i can't remember
now
oh the revelation of the cross and
resurrection
releasing us from every imagination of
alienation from the from the father's
grace just consider those things and i
said when you begin to deconstruct what
happens is there's there's a funneling
down almost
of
a lot of these things these certainties
just fall off to the side those things i
talked about before it no longer becomes
important whether or not we're going to
fight over that we're not no longer
going to need to fight over the
infallibility of scripture or the
possibility of eternal conscious torment
or any of these many things that that
are
heart
unsettled in our hearts
we hear them we don't want them to be
true
well there's some of them we want to be
true for that certain person
my wife asked the lady one time when
they were counseled with tell me who is
it that you want to go to hell
oh don't say that father we love you
thank you for this brief opportunity
and may their hearts be opened up to the
longer opportunity no not really
lord we love you and love these people
and thank you for the opportunity father
just to share just for a few moments
and i just thank you lord that it's your
holy spirit it's a teacher in the church
that you're the one that leads and
guides and that no man is their teacher
but you
and so i just entrust uh to you lord the
the fulfillment of anything that
needs to be made personal in any of
their lives and i just blessed this time
and i bless them in jesus name amen
all righty
oh it says i got 25 minutes on my timer
again
well i
i've got a few things to say too so but
you know when my wife and i got married
uh the pastor's cell phone went off
his alarm went off and it reminded me
this reminded me of when we got married
so that was
yeah fun times
so
just the
the song that i was talking to mindy
about doing is uh
it's a song that's on my heart i don't
i suppose somewhere it relates to
deconstruction but it really just
relates to kind of
what i've been going through the last
year year and a half and i guess what a
lot of people going going through in
some regards are on another
um
i mean it's no secret 2020 has been a
rough year i guess every every year as a
referee there's always challenges that
we we face
last september my mother passed away and
so i've been processing that
and um
you know and all the other challenges
we've we've had in 2020 and you know you
come into 2021 you think you're
processing it you're moving forward
you get a vac you know there's a
vaccination available so you think
things are going to get better on the
horizon
january 1st happened so now you've got a
new
number on the year it's not 2020 anymore
it's 2021 so everything's going to be
different and it just doesn't happen
like that you know it's not like there's
a light switch that you're
turning on or off
and um you know we've had i've had two
really good friends of mine
their mothers passed away about a week
ago one passed away from covet and
another one passed away from ovarian
cancer
both the lovely women that i've known
for years i've
knew one for over 40 years and the other
one for 30 years
and
um
so you you know
it's a different kind of
morning that you have
you mourn for your friends
and
you know some sometimes that just uh
makes you remember things that you know
you mourn for yourself
um there's things that you tell yourself
uh like you know hey they're in a better
place
or other people tell you these things
and mindy talked about this once a while
back
or
god has a plan
and you know
you know these are true
but they just don't make you feel better
[Music]
um the one thing that i do find uh
comfort in
is that
somewhere some someday we're all going
to be together
not here
but with jesus
that that i do
i do find solace in that that's what
this song's about it's called face to
face when we meet jesus face to face and
we meet him all together as a collective
together no exclusion
together
[Music]
i'm a traveler
far from home
and i get lost
but i press on
cause there's a mansion
and streets of gold
where i belong
there's a day
coming soon
where the own
will be made
new the heaven's glory
shines like the morning
before our eyes
[Music]
when we all
see jesus
[Music]
when we are
see jesus no
no more sickness
no more madness
no more pain
when we all
[Music]
see jesus
face to face
[Music]
then we will see
with angel's voices
there will be great
[Music]
rejoicing yeah
holy holy
[Music]
when we
see jesus
when we all
no more sickness
[Music]
no moment
no
more pain
no more pain
[Music]
jesus
when we all
[Music]
see jesus
face
[Music]
face to face
[Applause]
thank you carter
uh also thank you mike we appreciate
you bringing that message to us as well
um
and as we gonna kind of close i just
wanted to do just a quick reminder that
if um
we
hope that this brings you closer to god
we just always hope that this brings you
um in a deeper relationship with who god
is who jesus is
and don't know what you guys are going
through
throughout the week i was sharing
earlier with carter i said you know he
was asking me how my week was i was like
no
yeah it was fine um
you know there was some there were highs
there were lows or some mediocre moments
um and everything like that
but i
but
even within that mediocre we all still
need support
and
um if there's anything that i could help
um with if you need prayer with anything
i would love to be able to be able to do
that for you
at the end at the end of service
um
also if you're a visitor welcome we'd
like to get
learn a little bit more about you and
there's a place on the small table out
there where you can feel like a visitor
card we just
need a little bit information about you
also if you
would love to give to this ministry help
support us there's also an envelope in a
box be able to make donations you can
also do that online
at our website
as well under some directions also on
how to do so
and as we close out i'm just going to
send you off in this word of prayer
lord thank you so much again
uh for this ability and time to be able
to come together um
just to
be reminded of who you are
and be reminded of just kind of where we
are
in our relationship with you no matter
where we're at with our process of
trying to understand
just how
amazing and complex and
wonderful life is i pray that you will
give us strength and peace with all the
different things we have going on
and give us comfort as we go on this
week in christ and i pray amen
production
you